Hallo, guten Tag. Mein Name ist Ekrem Özvalım. Ich bin auf dieser Station als Asst. Arzt tätig.
Ich würde gerne mit dir in das Aufnahmegespräch führen. Alles in Ordnung für Sie?
Ja natürlich Herr Doktor.
Ok. Als erstes benötige ich ein paar persönliche Daten. Dann können wir weiterführen. Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Tobias Beckers.
Tobias Beckers. Herr Beckers, könnten Sie bitte Ihr Vornamen und Nachnamen langsam und deutlich buchstabieren?
Ja, natürlich. Tobias ist T-O-B-I-A-S.
Ok.
Beckers, Usta 40, B-E-C-K-E-R-S. Beckers.
Am Ende S.
Ok. Vielen Dank. Herr Beckers, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 42 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie geboren?
Am 1. Februar 1984.
Am 1. Februar 1984. Ok. Vielen Dank. Herr Beckers, wie groß sind Sie?
171 cm.
71 cm.
Ok.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ungefähr 80 kg. Entschuldigung, 60 kg.
64 kg.
64 kg, ja.
Ok. Vielen Dank. Was wissen Sie uns heute? Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Herr Doktor, also ehrlich gesagt, schlagt mein Herz richtig schnell. Ich spüre auch Herzklopfen und so ein enger Gefühl in der Brust.
Herzschlagen und enger Gefühl. Seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerden?
Seit heute Morgen. Heute Morgen.
Herr Doktor, woher kommt eigentlich Herzrasen? Ich habe ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen Angst.
Ja, für den Herzrasen könnte man viele Ursachen haben. Wir können ein paar Fragen stellen. Dann können wir widersprechen.
Herzschlagen und enger Gefühl haben Sie seit heute Morgen. Diese Beschwerden sind plötzlich oder langsam aufgetreten.
Plötzlich aufgetreten. Bekomme ich eine Krankschreibung? Ich kann so nicht arbeiten, Herr Doktor.
Ja, natürlich. Sie sind schon hier.
Krankschreibung.
Ja, deswegen sind Sie schon hier bei der Notaufnahme.
Ok, danke.
Deswegen ja. Und Sie haben schon gesagt, ich kann nicht so gut hören. Langsam auftreten, haben Sie gesagt, oder?
Diese Herzschlagen.
Plötzlich, Herr Doktor. Seit heute Morgen. Sie sind plötzlich angefangen. Deswegen bin ich hier.
Und vielleicht möchten Sie wissen, ich habe auch Bauchschmerzen, Herr Doktor.
Ja, noch Bauchschmerzen.
Ja.
Die Bauchschmerzen sind die gleichzeitig oder?
Nein, seit etwa drei Tagen habe ich diese Schmerzen.
Ok, drei Tage. Sie haben Bauchschmerzen. Ich habe das notiert. Und Herr Becker, gibt es eine bestimmte Auslöser für den Herzrahmen?
Also weiß ich nicht, Herr Doktor.
Haben Sie Atemnot aktuell?
Nein, ich nicht.
Im Moment ist der Herzrahmen dauerhaft oder?
Haben Sie noch Herzrahmen?
Ich kann nicht genau beschreiben.
Leider ist er da unten. Aber im Moment besser. Ja, ich fühle mich besser.
Ok, haben Sie noch Bauchschmerzen?
Nein, das habe ich nicht.
Ok, kein Bauchschmerzen. Alles gut.
Ich habe Bauchschmerzen, Herr Doktor.
Bauchschmerzen. Herr Becker, ist das das erste Mal aufgetreten oder haben Sie vorher einiges beschwert?
Eigentlich schon seit zehn Jahren immer wieder.
Zehn Jahre. Ungebetlich.
Früher waren sie schwächer. Vielleicht. Aber es wird langsam immer schlimmer.
Mittagszeit immer schlimmer geworden.
Ich würde gerne wissen, Herr Becker, Herzrasen und Bauchschmerzen. Immer gleichsätzlich oder?
Herzrasen zum ersten Mal.
Hab ich bemerkt. Aber Bauchschmerzen habe ich seit Langem.
Vor drei Monaten hatte ich deswegen eine Magenspiegelung bei meinem Hausarzt.
Vor drei Monaten?
Ja, wegen dieser Bauchschmerzen.
Da war angeblich alles unauffällig, Herr Doktor.
Unauffällig.
Ja, diese Magenspiegelung meine ich.
Haben Sie das Ergebnis dabei oder?
Ich kann Ihnen den Namen von meinem Hausarzt geben.
Ja, okay. Wie heißt Ihr Hausarzt?
Frau Müller.
Frau Müller, okay. Ich werde mit Frau Müller in Verbindung setzen. Okay, kein Problem.
Und dann können Sie bitte die Bauchschmerzen genau beschreiben.
Wie dunkel, kolikartig und brennendstehend. Wie würden Sie diese Schmerzen beschreiben?
Ich würde sagen, drückend und manchmal kolikartig.
Drückend und kolikartig.
Herr Doktor, ich habe mich daran erinnert, besonders nach dem Essen habe ich diese Schmerzen.
Das fängt an, nachdem ich im Thai-Restaurant war. Ich habe dort Tofu.
Ich habe dort Tofu mit Reis und Gemüse gegessen. Wissen Sie, was das ist?
Ja, ja, ja. Tofu in eine thailändische Speise. Ich vermute.
Meine Frau hat mich übrigens gezwungen dorthin zu gehen.
Ich wollte eigentlich lieber etwas anderes essen, aber das habe ich gegessen.
Ja, ich wüsste es.
Ja, danach habe ich das bekommen. Habe ich diese Schmerzen bekommen.
Okay, ich wüsste es. Wann haben Sie das gegessen? Tofu?
Vor drei Tagen, ja.
Vor drei Tagen?
Bevor ich diese Schmerzen bekommen habe, ja.
Okay. Herr Becker, erstrahlen Sie die Schmerzen irgendwo hinaus?
Eigentlich nicht.
Die Schmerzen sind auf dem Bauch oder Magen.
Hier, Herr Dr.?
Ja.
Oberbauch.
Oberbauch, okay. Oberbauchschmerzen seit drei Tagen.
Okay. Gibt es etwas, das die Schmerzen verstärkt oder lindert?
Das habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Sie haben es schon gesagt, nach dem Versen.
Ich habe auch Übelkeit und wenn ich mich übergebe, fühle ich mich besser.
Vielleicht kann es eine Linderung und Faktor sein für Sie?
Okay. Nach dem Übergeben der Schmerzen geht es ein bisschen besser.
Okay, ich habe das nutzt.
Herr Becker, Ihre Frau oder Ihre Kinder haben auch eine Schmerzen seit drei Tagen oder nur bei Ihnen.
Wie bitte?
Gibt es noch jemanden, der gleiches Essen gegessen hat?
Zum Beispiel Ihre Frau hat Tofu gegessen oder?
Sie hat auch Tofu gegessen, aber sie hat keine solche Beschwerden.
Keine solche Beschwerden, okay.
Sie haben schon gesagt, vor drei Monaten wegen einer Beschwerden bei Ihrem Hausarzt eine Ökede durchgeführt wurde.
Was ist so gegangen, Herr Doktor?
Sie haben Magenschwiegelung gesagt.
Okay, genau.
Das war unauffällig.
Okay.
Herr Becker, wie stark sind die Schmerzen?
Wie beschreiben Sie, nur kein Schmerzen, 10 sehr sehr starke Schmerzen entspricht?
Wie würden Sie mir die Schmerzen beschreiben auf eine Schmerzskala?
Herr Doktor, etwa drei von zehn.
Kann ich so sagen, nach dem Essen etwas stärker.
Und wie stark nach dem Essen?
Viel, aber bestimmt stärker.
Okay, haben Sie noch dagegen einen Medikament angenommen oder?
Nein, Herr Doktor.
Okay.
Herr Becker, haben Sie Fieber?
Entschuldigung.
Ein Moment.
Herr Becker, haben Sie Fieber?
Kann ich nicht hören, leider.
Ich denke, Blut ist aktiv.
Hören Sie mich gut?
Kann ich Sie nicht gut hören?
Nein.
Leider habe ich nicht gehört.
Ich denke ...
Hallo, Herr Becker?
Kannst du mich hören?
Ja, sehr gut.
Entschuldigung.
Vielen Dank.
Und ...
Ich habe eine Frage vergessen.
Okay.
Herr Becker, haben Sie noch gesagt, kein Fieber, Stahlfluss?
Ich habe kein Fieber, Herr Doktor.
Nach Schmeiß, Schmeißen, Inkontrol?
Das habe ich nicht bemerkt, ja.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder Stuhlgang?
Das habe ich nicht bemerkt, aber manchmal leide ich Durchfall, Herr Doktor.
Ich habe jetzt ... Entschuldigung, ich leide darunter.
Seit gestern.
Durchfall seit gestern?
Ja, ja.
Durchfall seit gestern.
Wie sah es aus?
Der Stuhl ist eher brech und flüssig, Herr Doktor.
War auch dunkelbraun.
Aber es gibt kein Blut.
Ah.
Bestrück.
Okay, auch kein Blut.
Ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie noch Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Nein, das habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Okay.
Aber Herr Doktor, möchten Sie wissen, ich kann mich auch schlecht konzentrieren auf irgendetwas?
Seit wann haben Sie Konzentrationsstörungen?
Ist dauerhaft oder ...?
Dauerhaft.
Ja, manchmal leide ich darunter.
Manchmal, okay.
Fühlen Sie sich müde oder ...?
Ja, ich fühle mich auch müde.
Schlafen Sie gut in der Nacht?
Haben Sie Probleme ein oder durchschlafen?
Herr Doktor, wegen dieser Schmerzen kann ich nicht gut schlafen.
Wegen dieser Schmerzen?
Ja.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Leiden Sie an irgendwelchen Erkrankungen?
Herr Becker zum Beispiel, Zuckerkrankheit, Bluthochdruck oder ...?
Herr Doktor, ich habe übrigens Ferse Schmerzen.
Wissen Sie wo genau die Ferse ist?
Ferse Schmerzen, ja.
Könnten Sie sich das vielleicht anschauen?
Ja, natürlich. Am Ende dieses Gesprächs werde ich alles sehen.
Ich frage mich ob man das operieren muss.
Okay, Herr Doktor.
Sie haben nach meinen Krankheiten gefragt.
Ich habe Blutdruck seit zwei Jahren.
Zwei Jahre. Bluthochdruck.
Ja, Bluthochdruck, ja.
Bluthochdruck, ja.
Gibt es noch etwas?
Nein, Herr Doktor.
Ferse Schmerzen?
Ja, ja.
Dauerhaftig? Chronisch meinen Sie?
Wenn ich laufen ...
Wegen dieser Bestreiten waren Sie schon einmal bei Ihrem Hausarzt oder?
Nein, Herr Doktor.
Gibt es keine bestimmte Diagnose?
Nein.
Dann machen Sie Ferse Schmerzen. Okay.
Nehmen Sie Medikament gegen Bluthochdruck?
Natürlich, Herr Doktor. Ich nehme Nebivolol und Amlodipin.
Nebivolol und wie viel Milligramm wissen Sie?
Nebivolol ist 2,5 Milligramm und auch Amlodipin 2,5 Milligramm.
2,5 Milligramm. Beide?
Ja.
2,5 Milligramm.
Herr Doktor, ist Bluthochdruck eigentlich ärmlich?
Ja, könnte sein. Aber gibt es viele Verständnissachen.
Zum Beispiel Lebensstil, Rauchen, Alkohol trinken, Sport treiben, Gewicht reduzieren.
Gibt es viele Verständnisse.
Nicht nur ärmlich.
Haben Sie schon einmal operiert, Herr Becker?
Herr Doktor, ich hatte Mandelentfernung.
Mandelentfernung?
Ja, weil ich 11 Jahre war.
11 Jahre war in Schildegurje.
Okay, das verkommt Kastronen aus oder?
Nach der Operation habe ich viel geschlafen, Herr Doktor.
Also hatte ich Übelkeit und musste ich mich übergeben.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Ist das normal?
Ja, nicht normal, aber nicht so schlimm. Manchmal könnte es so sein.
Okay.
Können wir es so sehen nach dem Vollnarkose. Ist das möglich?
Okay, gibt es noch andere Operationen?
Ja, okay.
Mandelentfernung.
Okay. Herr Becker, haben Sie Allergien?
Ich habe Erdnussallergie, Herr Doktor.
Erdnussallergie?
Wie ist das?
Wenn ich Erdnuss esse, bekomme ich dann Bränen im Mund, Schwitzen und Yukreis.
Schwitzen, Yukreis, Bränen im Mund oder?
Nein, das habe ich nicht, aber diese drei habe ich.
Okay.
Herr Becker, nehmen Sie regelmäßig gegen Bluthochdruck, Nebulor und Amlodipin?
Sie haben es schon gesagt.
Gibt es noch andere Medikamente?
Gelegenheit oder regelmäßig?
Nein. Zum Beispiel einen Magenschutz?
Herr Doktor, wie gesagt, habe ich keine anderen Medikamente.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Oder nehme ich keine anderen Medikamente ein.
Okay. Sind Sie vollgeimpft?
Ja, Herr Doktor. Gegen Corona und Pneumatik und Influenza.
Waren Sie in der letzten Zeit im Ausland?
Nein, Herr Doktor.
Keine andere Ansicht.
Herr Becker, leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Herr Doktor, ja, sie leben noch, aber sie haben manche gesundheitliche Probleme.
Mein Vater hat auch Bluthochdruck und Grünescht.
Grünescht, okay.
Unter Kontrolle oder?
Ich hoffe es, ja.
Er hat mit 63 Lebensjahren einen Herzanschlag erlebt.
Wann haben Sie gesagt?
Weil er 63 Jahre alt war. Entschuldigung, alles.
Ja, okay. Herzgebrach.
Erlitten. Okay. Und?
Herr Doktor, ist Grünescht erblich?
Ja, könnte sein, aber ehrlich gesagt kann ich nicht genau sagen.
Sie sollen für dieses Thema mit einem Augenarzt spielen.
Kann ich nicht genau sagen. Ja, könnte sein.
Meine Mutter hat Altersdiabe, Alterszucker, Herr Doktor.
Und sie hat auch Hühnerauge.
Soll sie auch einen Augenarzt besuchen?
Für dich Hühnerauge?
Sie sollen einen Orthopäden aussuchen, ich denke.
Herr Becker, haben Sie eine Schwester?
Herr Becker?
Herr Doktor, ich habe eine Schwester.
Eine Schwester? Ist sie gesund?
Nein Herr Doktor, sie leidet mit Magendan Problemen.
Magendan Problemen? Okay.
Herr Becker, sind Sie verheiratet?
Herr Doktor, ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Ja, haben Sie schon gesagt. Haben Sie Kinder? Wie viele Kinder haben Sie?
Ja, wir haben eine sechsjährige Tochter.
Sechsjährige Tochter. Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Kommunikationsdesigner.
Ich arbeite Vollzeit, Herr Doktor. Aber zum Glück bin ich damit zufrieden.
Sehr gut, sehr gut. Das freut mich.
Kommunikationdesigner.
Herr Becker, ich bin noch mit meinen Fragen fertig.
Möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen?
Herr Doktor, möchten Sie vielleicht, ob ich rauche oder trinke?
Ja, Entschuldigung, Sie haben mich auf meinem Blatt geschrieben.
Deswegen vergesse ich. Rauchen Sie?
Nein Herr Doktor, ich rauche nie.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Naja, vielleicht zwei bis drei Gläser Schnaps oder Wein am Abend. Am Wochenende etwas mehr.
Etwas mehr. Zwei oder drei Gläser Wein.
Schnaps trinke ich.
Am Wochenende noch mehr.
Ja, etwas mehr.
Meine Frau sagt immer, ich sei ein Schluckspecht. Wissen Sie, was das heißt?
Oder denken Sie auch, dass ich ein Schluckspecht bin?
Ich denke nicht so. Ich denke das so nicht.
Aber können Sie bitte versuchen, Ihre Alkohol zu konsumieren?
Ein bisschen reduzieren.
Okay, ich versuche.
Es wäre besser für Ihre Gesundheit und besonders Magen, Daumen und Essengewohnheit.
Vielen Dank Herr Becker. Ich bin nun mit meinen Fragen fertig.
Danke für die Gedanken.
Haben Sie noch Fragen?
Herr Doktor, was habe ich? Was denken Sie? Sie haben am Anfang gesagt, dass Sie am Ende meine Herzrasen erklären.
Oder die Gründe dieser Herzrasen erklären.
Herr Becker, was habe ich? Hauptsache ich meine Backschmerzen und Herzrasen.
Ich habe einen Verdacht auf die Empfindlichkeit des Magen und Daumen.
Aber das bleibt nur eine Vernutung.
Ich werde Ihren Körper untersuchen und dann ein paar Blut abnehmen.
Dann gegebenenfalls einen Ultraschall durchführen.
Und auch gegebenenfalls einen gesund-theratologischen Konsil anfordern.
Dann werde ich mit Ihrem Hausarzt, Ihrer Hausarzt Frau Mila, haben Sie schon gesagt, in Verbindung setzen.
Ich brauche Ihre Magenspiegel und Ergebnisse.
Und dann können wir, sobald die Ergebnisse vorliegen, über dieses Thema besprechen.
Warum sind mein Magen und Daumen empfindlich, Herr Doktor? Sie haben so gesagt.
Vielleicht kann es sein, dass Sie zu Hause wegen Stress sind.
Ich streite immer mit meiner Frau. Ich habe viel Stress zu Hause.
Sie haben nicht gesagt, Sie haben gefragt, aber ich habe viel Stress zu Hause.
Obwohl ich bei der Arbeit keinen Stress habe, habe ich viel Stress zu Hause.
Ja, Entschuldigung. Ich verstehe Sie. Sie haben seit ca. 10 Jahren Ähnliches beschwert.
Sie sind nicht Raucher. Aber täglich trinken Sie 2 oder 3 Gläser Wein am Abend.
Sie haben vor 3 Monaten Oberschmerzen.
Weil Ihnen eine Magenspiegelung durchgeführt wurde.
Aber keine auffälligen Ergebnisse. Und deswegen habe ich gedacht,
dass meine Vordiagnose eine Magen-Darm-Empfindlichkeit ist.
Dann können wir weiter untersuchen und durchführen.
Sobald alle Ergebnisse vorliegen, können wir wieder besprechen.
Alles in Ordnung? Vielen Dank, Herr Doktor.
Bis dann.
Das war es für heute.
Frau Omer, darf ich ein paar Fragen stellen?
Ja, natürlich.
Für den Patienten. Für Herrn Beckers.
Herr Beckers, strahlen Ihre Schmerzen irgendwo aus?
Zum Beispiel im Unterbauch oder im Hals?
Danach wurde gefragt.
Ich habe keine Anstrangung.
Ich habe akustisch nicht gut gehört.
Haben Sie Gewichtveränderungen in der letzten Zeit?
Nein. Es ist immer stabil.
Okay. Wann war Ihre letzte Blutdruckmessung?
Kontrollieren Sie Ihre Blutdruck regelmäßig?
Ja, ich achte darauf.
Das war normal. 120 zu 70.
Wann war diese?
Vor zwei Tagen.
Das ist gut.
Haben Sie irgendetwas gegen Naurensmittel? Unverträglichkeit?
Ja, wenn ich etwas Scharfes esse,
bekomme ich Probleme wie Durchfall, Übelkeit und Bauchschmerzen.
Gestes Essen war auch mit Scharfes? Was denken Sie?
Gestes Essen, gestes Tof, war Scharfes oder?
Es gibt Gewürze, aber nicht so scharf.
Vielen Dank für die Information.
Kling Kling.
Guten Morgen. Frau Müller aus dem Labor.
Guten Morgen, Frau Müller.
Eine Werte von Frau Bergheim.
Frau Bergheim.
Kaliumwert von 2,6 Millimol pro Liter.
Könnten Sie diese Werte bitte Ihrer Operarztin weiterleiten?
Ja, natürlich. Frau Müller, vielen Dank für die Information.
Okay. Guten Tag. Tschüss.
Guten Tag. Frau Oberstin.
Woher kommen Sie her aus Jualen?
Ich komme aus der Türkei. Frau Oberstin.
Seit wann sind Sie in Deutschland?
Seit 3 Jahren bin ich in Deutschland mit meiner Familie.
Okay. Was haben Sie bisher in Deutschland gemacht?
Ich habe Deutschkurs, alle Niveau, B1, B2 und Fachsprachprüfung gemacht.
Und 3-malige Hospitalikationen.
Welche Fachrichtungen haben Sie in der Fachrichtung gemacht?
Gastroentologe, Urologie und Arthritis.
Haben Sie etwas bemerkt, ob es einen Unterschied zwischen dem Türkei- und dem deutschen Gesundheitssystem gibt?
Wie soll ich sagen?
Ja, das Gesundheitssystem ist bei uns ein bisschen gut kontrolliert.
Bei uns ist das Gesundheitssystem nicht so gut kontrolliert.
Und die Patientbelastung ist sehr hoch.
Ich bewundere mich und das Gesundheitssystem.
Ich bewundere sich das Gesundheitssystem.
Und das Verschämungssystem.
Okay.
Haben Sie Erfahrung in der Türkei?
Ja, ich bin seit ca. 13 Jahren Facharzt für Urologie.
Ich arbeite in der Türkei über Uro-Onkologie.
Aber seit ca. 3 Jahren bin ich arbeitslos in Deutschland.
Ich möchte wieder als Arzt in Deutschland.
In welchen Fachrichtungen würden Sie gerne arbeiten?
Wieder in Urologie oder in Arthritis?
Natürlich in meinem Bereich.
Ich möchte wieder fortführen.
Was haben Sie noch heute für uns?
Ich habe einen Patienten, Herr Tobias Becker, 42 Jahre alt, gewonnen 1984.
Bevor Sie mir über Ihren Patienten vorstellen,
haben Sie noch andere wichtige Mitteile?
Ja, das habe ich leider vergessen.
Bevor ich meine Patienten vorstellen möchte,
möchte ich mit ihnen etwas wichtiges mitteilen.
Gerade Frau Müller aus dem Labor war angerufen.
Frau Bergheim, eine Kaliumwerte 2,6 mV pro Liter.
Diese Werte sind deutlich erniedrigt und entspricht einer Hypokaliemi.
Was ist der häufigste Ursache für die Kaliumwerte?
Die Ursache ist meistens Diuretik.
Die Einnahme der Diuretik und Diarrhochabbrüche,
Alkohol, respiratorische und metabolische.
Das könnte Ursache sein.
Die Befunde sind Muskelschwäche, Kraftverlust, Krampf,
Reflexstörungen, Schwierigkeiten, Obstipation und am wichtigsten Kammerflamme.
Wie können Sie diese behandeln?
Die leichtste Form, die wir unter über 2,5 mV haben,
ist die kaliumreiche Ernährung, zum Beispiel Ost- und Obst, Bananen.
Bei der schweren Form wird die kaliumreiche Ernährung mit Parantheral-Kaliumchlorid behandelt.
Was haben Sie noch?
Ich habe einen neuen Patienten, Tobias Becker, 42 Jahre alt, erstes, zweites, 1985 geboren.
1,71 m groß und 64 kg.
Herr Becker steht heute bei uns seit gestern Abend plötzlich auf getretenen,
Herzschlagen und enge Gefühle.
Laut Angaben der Patienten hat er seit drei Tagen Bauchschmerzen.
Er war vor drei Monaten bei ihrem Hausarzt, bei ihm,
einem Magenspiegel durchgeführt worden.
Die Schmerzcharakter sind dunklen und kolikartig.
Die Schmerzen strahlen nicht aus.
Er gab an, dass die Schmerzen besonders nach dem Essen auffällig sind.
Die Schmerzintensität liegt bei 3 von 10 auf einer Schmerzskala.
Nach dem Versuch liegt die Schmerzintensität bei 4 von 10.
Begleitend ist die Übelkeit, besonders nach dem Versuch,
seit drei Tagen gleichzeitig durchfällig.
Das sieht wässrig, dunkelbraun und breit aus, ohne Blut.
Wegen der Schmerzbedingte sind Schlafstörungen und Konzentrationen.
Begegnet von amnestisch gab er an eine Konzentrationsstörung
und Schmerzbedingte Schlafstörungen bis auf unauffällig.
Gewichtveränderung würde verneint.
Bei der Vorerkrankung an amnese
erhielt er eine Hypatonie und er hatte eine Fersen-Schmerzen.
Bei der Voroperation erwendete sie mit 80 Lebensjahre bei ihm
und wurde ein Tonsilektron durchgeführt.
Bei der Allergischen amnese
erwendete sie eine Erdnutzallergie.
Er reagierte mit Juckreis und Schweißausbruch.
Bei Medikamentos erhielt er regelmäßig 2,5 mg Nebulol
und 2,5 mg Amlodipin täglich morgens.
Er ist nicht Raucher.
Er konsumierte 2 oder 3 Gläser Wein am Abend.
Den Drogenkonsum habe ich leider nicht gefragt.
Bei der Familienanalyse
gibt es Arterialhypatonie und Grüne Schta bei dem Vater.
Auch mit 18. und 68. Lebensjahr
hat der Vater einen Herzinfarkt erlitten.
Bei der Mutter ist Diabetes mellitus type 2 bekannt.
Er hat eine Schwester.
Die Schwester hat Magen-Darm-Probleme.
Er ist verheiratet, hat eine Tochter.
Er ist Kommunikation-Designer.
Aufgrund der Diabetes habe ich den Verdacht auf Reismagensyndrom.
Wofür spricht das?
Ja, chronische Bauchschmerzen.
Die Bauchschmerzen kommen nach dem Versuch.
Circa 10 Jahre hatte er Ähnliches beschwert.
Die Frau hat vor 3 Monaten bei ihrem Haus eine Magenspiegelung durchgeführt.
Das Ergebnis war unaufällig.
Die Schmerzcharakter ist trocken, kolikartig.
Nach dem Versuch
hat er eine sehr ausgeprägte Überleitung und Durchfall dafür entspricht.
Hat er Stress bei der Arbeit?
Ja, er hat schon gesagt,
er hatte zu Hause viel Stress.
Er hatte mit seiner Frau Probleme.
Auch Alkoholprobleme.
Bei seiner Schwester hatte er Ähnliches beschwert.
Was hat seine Frau ihm gesagt?
Aufgrund des Alkoholkonsums.
Schluckspecht.
Was bedeutet Schluckspecht?
Alkoholiker.
Alkoholistik.
Was ist ihre Französisch?
Schluckspecht.
Die Französischen Diagnostik kommen
in Gastroesophagealrefluxkrankheit und Akutkoronar-Syndrome.
Um meine Verdacht Diagnose zu bestätigen,
Entschuldigung, Gastroesophagealrefluxkrankheit und
Akutkoronar-Syndrome.
Leidet er unter Luftnot, Brustmerzen?
Nein, der Patient leidet nicht.
Aber am Anfang hat er gesagt,
seit heute Morgen, er hat Herzschlagen und
Engelgefühl.
Und der Patient,
Okay, was denken Sie daran, warum er einen Herzschlag,
Engelgefühl, Probleme hat?
Das bleibt nur eine Differenzdiagnose, um
eine Herzursache zu ausschließen.
Ist für mich sehr wichtig.
Deswegen möchte ich diese Optionen ausschließen.
Ja, Sie haben recht.
Ich habe eine andere Frage gestellt.
Was denken Sie darum,
warum er einen Herzschlag oder Engelgefühlprobleme
haben kann?
Der Patient ist 42 Jahre alt.
Der Vater hat einen Herzinfarkt gesichtet.
Und der Patient hat seit heute Morgen
Herzschlagen, Engelgefühl und
Akoholkonsum.
Deswegen könnte ein Akutkoronar-Syndrome sein.
Ja, aber ich möchte hören.
Er hat viel Stress.
Das kann auch
schnelle Herzschlagprobleme verursachen.
Auch Schmerzen kann auf
Und er klagt über
Durchfall.
Hat er einen Erbruch?
Ja, erbruch? Nein.
Erbruch nach dem Tversen.
Erbruch von Elektrolytstörungen.
Durchfall kann Elektrolytstörungen verursachen.
Und Elektrolytstörungen oder Elektrolytenveränderungen
sind auch die Ursache für Herzschlag.
Ja, natürlich.
Ich möchte diese Antwort hören.
Bezüglich Ihrer Patienten.
Sie haben Recht.
Die Diagnose ist Reisdarm-Syndrom.
Aber die ersten Maßnahmen, die erste Stelle steht,
ist Stress. Aber ich habe immer vergessen.
Nein.
Eigentlich gesagt,
nicht bezüglich seiner Diagnose,
bezüglich seiner Beschwerden.
Stress ist eine Beschwerde.
Durchfall, Erbrechen ist eine Beschwerde.
Schmerzen ist eine Beschwerde.
Diese Beschwerden können Herzschlagprobleme,
schnelle Herzschlagprobleme verursachen.
Ich möchte diese Antwort hören.
Das ist eine sehr breite Frage.
Was könnte für den Herzschlag oder Herzrasen verursachen?
Diese große Frage.
Ja, Sie haben Recht.
Dann gibt es einen Elektrolyteverlust,
Flüssigkeitverlust, Schmerzen und Stress.
Ich meine bei diesem Fall.
Deswegen möchte ich nur die Beschwerden
des Patients hören.
Vielen Dank.
Ich würde gerne als Erstes eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Dann Blut für das Labor abnehmen.
Bei der Labor Blutbild, Nieren und Leberwerte
und Instruktion Werte, Herzansüme bestimmen lassen.
Oder kontrollieren lassen.
Ich schreibe eine in Ruhe EKG.
Hab ich noch Herzansüme gesagt?
Ja.
Ich werde mit Ihren Hausarztinnen und Hausarztinnen in Verbindung setzen
für die Ergebnisse der bisherigen Magenschwiegerung
oder der Fabula-Sodium-Dynastie.
Wenn es nötig ist, eine neue Ösefabula-Sodium-Dynastie zu verabreichen,
eine gastroenterologische Konzertantwortung zu verantworten.
An welcher Situation oder an welcher Beschwerde
würden Sie noch einmal Magenschwiegerung veranlassen?
Blutung, eine neue Blutung, Gewichtverlust, Schmerzentestechsteigerung
und Gewichtverlust, Schmerzentestechsteigerung.
Und familiäre Belastung?
Ja, das reicht.
Die Veränderung der Beschwerden?
Ja, es gibt 6 oder 7 Veränderungen.
Aber Sie müssen nicht alle Ursachen nennen.
Blutungen, Gewichtveränderungen, Best-Symptomatik,
genetische Belastung und Veränderung der Beschwerden.
Das reicht.
Als Therapie würde ich gerne diese Patienten ambulant behandeln.
Diese Patienten würden ambulant behandelt werden.
Als Initialtherapie Anarchetika, Antispasmolytika
und Protonpomphalema.
Dann die Lebensstilveränderung,
die Alkoholkehren und Ernährung,
die Einstellung der Patienten, das ist sehr wichtig für mich.
Ich kann natürlich die Flüssigkeit konsumieren.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Ekrem, wir werden die Fragen gleich generell sprechen.
Da können Sie sich die Fragen selbst vorstellen.
Es ist wichtig, dass Sie sich hier auch systematisch vorstellen.
Sie haben heute den Herzrasen gesagt, dann den Bauchmersen,
dann die Doktorin, die 10 Jahre lang geblieben ist.
Dann haben Sie die Fragen zum Bauchmersen gesagt.
Dann kommen Sie zum Bauchmersen, dann zum Engagefer,
dann zum Bauchmersen, dann zum Bauchmersen,
dann zum Endniveau, dann zum Endniveau.
Dann kommen Sie zum Begleitsemptom.
Das ist nicht falsch, aber es ist schön,
dass es eine bestimmte Struktur und eine bestimmte Runde gibt.
Deswegen können Sie die Hände auf einander verändern.
Wir gehen nicht nur um die Anamnese, sondern um die Klinikverwaltung.
Sie können die Anamnese nicht nur um die Klinik verwenden,
sondern auch um die Anamnese verwenden.
Dann kann man es auch von der Anamnese sehen.
Man kann es auch von der Anamnese sehen.
Aber dann muss man auf die 2. Anamnese schauen.
Das sind grammatische Fehler, aber man kann es mit einer Anamnese machen.
Das ist ein Problem.
Man kann es auch mit einer Anamnese sehen.
Aber das ist besser.
Das ist einfach.
Das, weil, ob.
Ich mache das auch bei mir, aber ich mache das auch bei mir.
Ich bin auf der Bühne.
Ja, ich hoffe, dass es euch besser geht.
Okay, dann muss es die zweite Ipek abnehmen.
Hier, Ipek.
Ich kann heute auch nicht die Kamera öffnen?
Du kannst es.
Okay, Reiss, Adam.
Es ist mir wirklich immer so schwierig, das zu machen.
Du hast keine Kaltklappel hören.
Ich bin ein kleiner Patient.
Ich kann keine leidenschaftlichen Patienten lieben, sagt Reiss.
Du sagst, dass ich deswegen da bin.
Ja, woher, was ich denn hier herzubekommen?
Das ist wirklich sehr anstrengend.
Du hast den ersten Versuch, dann die Bavarschmersen zu suchen,
dann die Annihe 5, Begleitsamtom, Vegetative Anamnese, Weita.
Die Beispiele sind klar.
Wie einfach habe ich es gesagt, oder?
Du sagst, dass du es einfach machst, aber ich mache es.
Ich werde die Kamera noch öffnen.
Ich bin leider ein Mensch, der keine Kopie kann.
Ich verstehe es, ich kann nicht külern.
Ich kann es mir nicht begehen.
Ich bin mir sicher, dass ich es mit dem Anamnesbogen machen kann.
Ich weiß nicht, ob alle meine Fakten so sind.
Reiss Darm sagt, dass die Protokolle am Anfang
die Schiprischt-Fil-Erweint-Unnötige-Infos sind.
Das ist wie die Schmersen.
Das ist so.
Die Unnötige sind etwas komplex.
Genau, das sagt er.
Er kann das nicht sein.
Er hat viele Beispiele.
Psychosomatische Beispiele sind viele.
Er weiß nicht, welcher der wichtig ist, welcher nicht.
Er sagt, dass er eine Rolle spielt,
aber ich sage es für die wirklichen Patienten.
Was sind psychologische Patienten für sich?
Ich weiß nicht, ob es wichtig ist für die anderen.
Er sagt, er sagt, er sagt.
Deswegen ist es schwierig, sie zu beenden.
Der ist ein wichtigster Typ.
Er sagt, er sei ein wichtigster Typ.
Das ist ein bisschen schwierig.
Das war der Grund, warum ich Psychiater-Hilfen nicht lieben wollte.
Es ist nicht leicht, sehr viel zu sagen und die wichtigen Dinge zu machen.
Echt, es ist sehr schwierig, solche Patienten zu gestalten.
Wie leicht ist es, eine Branche zu machen?
Wenn du einen Klappschluss auf den Hals hast, verliert man dich.
Du sagst, dass du den Patienten abholen kannst.
Ich glaube, das ist auch leicht.
Simeer-Hilfen weiß noch mehr, dass du den Effektor verhäust.
Das verhäust du, das verhäust du.
Das bringt nichts anderes.
Ich sage das mit meiner genannten Erfahrung.
Das war eine kurze Note. Danke.
Guten Tag Frau Oberarztin.
Ich habe einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen,
aber bevor ich ihn Ihnen einen wichtigen Gast teile,
habe ich einen Anruf aus dem Labor.
Frau Bergheim, Kaliumwert von 2,6 Millimitern pro Liter.
Dieser Wert ist deutlich erniedrigt und entschiebt eine Hypokalämie.
Darf ich jetzt meinen Patienten vorstellen?
Ja, natürlich. Aber bevor Sie mir Ihre Patienten vorstellen,
möchte ich ein paar Fragen nach Hypokalämie stellen.
Darf ich?
Ja, gerne.
Was ist der häufigste Ursache für Hypokalämie?
Dieuretikabnahme oder dieuretikainnahme erbrechen Übelkeit.
Auch Durchfall nicht Übelkeit, erbrechen Durchfall.
Jetzt können Sie Ihre Patienten vorstellen.
Es geht um Tobias Becker. Er ist 42 Jahre alt, geboren am 1.2.1964.
Er ist 1,61 Meter groß und wiegt 4,60 Kilogramm.
Er kann zu uns wehren, seit heute Morgen Herzrasen und ein Engelgefühl im Brust.
Die Frage nach Brustschmerzen und Atemnot ist unauffällig.
Er berichtet auch seit drei Tagen über Bauchschmerzen ohne Strahlung.
Die Schmerzcharakter ist drückend und kolikartig.
Nachdem gestern Erklagt über Erklagt über die Schmerzen nachdem Tofu die Schmerzen
gestern Abend nach dem Tofu verziert.
Er hat Unverträglichkeit gegen Scharfessen.
Er erwinnt auch zu Hause viel Stress.
Verstärkt Faktoren dieser Schmerzen ist Postprandial.
Er erwinnt auch, dass er vor drei Monaten eine Ösophageal Gastrodiadontoskopie von Hausarzten erzielt.
Er erwinnt, dass er vor drei Monaten eine Ösophageal Gastrodiadontoskopie erzielt.
Er erwinnt, dass er vor drei Monaten eine Ösophageal Gastrodiadontoskopie von Hausarzten erzielt.
Er berichtet auch seit gestern Durchfall.
Das sah aus Brei, wässrig, aber kein Blut.
Nachdem Tofu berichtet er auch Erbrechen.
Dann fühlt er sich besser.
Begleitend sind Konzentrationsstörungen, Müdigkeit und als vegetative Anamnese
Er gab sich in Appetens schmerzbedingte Insomni und als Vorerkrankungen hat er Bluthochdruck seit zwei Tagen.
Er hat Arterielle Hypertonie seit zwei Tagen.
Er hat die Kontrolle seit zwei Tagen und 21 Suh.
Er hat 2,5 mg Nebivolol und 2,5 mg Amlodipin.
In der operativen Anamnese findet sich Tonsillektomie vor fünf Jahren.
Bei der Allergenanamnese erwinnt er Erdnüsse Allergie.
Er reagiert darauf Schweißausbrüche und Pyruritis im Mund und Unverträglichkeit gegen Scharfessen.
Er hat die Noxenanamnese über den Alkoholkonsum, zwei Gläser Wein am Abend, Drogen und Rauchen konsum würden verleint.
Er ist verheiratet. Er hat eine Tochter, aber er erwähnt viel Stress zu Hause.
Die Familie ergab Bluthochdruck und Grünerstaff beim Vater und Diabetes mellitus Typ 2 beim Mutter.
Er ist voll geimpft und keine Schmerzen.
Aufgrund anamnistischen Angaben habe ich einen Verdacht auf Reismargendam-Syndrom.
Die Bauchschmerzen sind ohne Ausstrahlung, Durchfall ohne Blut und der fehlende pathologische Befund in der ÖGD oder Ösephagoga-Sodionoskopie vor drei Monaten.
Er hat Stress im Leben und manchmal im Arbeiten. Er spricht für den Alkoholkonsum.
Die Differenzia-Diagnose kommt mit Akutkorenar-Syndrom und Akutgastritis in Betracht.
Um die Verdacht-Diagnose zu bestätigen, würde ich zuerst körperliche Untersuchungen durchführen sowie Vitalparameter aufwachen, Inspektion, Palpation, Überprüfen, Überwachen und etwas mehr.
Außerdem ist es wichtig, EKG zu schreiben, um Herzkrankheit zu schließen.
Im Labor würde ich Blutbild, Entzündungsparameter, Troponin und Kardiakenzymes, Herzenzymes, Elektrolyt, Blutsuka, Nierenwerte, Osteoporne, Blutschmerzen, Obst und Bauchschmerzen,
Herzensüme, Elektrolyt, Blutzucker, Nierenwerte und Lebewerte bestimmen lassen.
Natürlich würde ich auch Ultraschall durchführen.
Echo meine ich.
Und anschließend werde ich das Ergebnis der ÖGD erfragen und ein psychiatrisches Konzil anfordern.
Sollte sich die Verdacht Diagnose bestätigen, wäre ich eine Ambulanttherapie sehen wollen.
Aber natürlich würde ich den Patienten symptomatische Behandlung planen.
Ich würde eine körperliche Bewegung, Gymnastik oder andere soziale Vereinungen mit teilen.
Das war alles.
Vielen Dank.
Ich wünsche dir eine gute Zeit.
Ich glaube, dass ich die Erleichterung sehr gut gemacht habe.
Ich glaube, dass die Versorgung der Patienten sehr gut war.
Die letzten Fälle sprechen wir über die Erleichterung der Patienten.
Die Erleichterung der Patienten ist sehr gut.
Sie hat eine hohe Begegnung.
Sie hat ein hohes Begegnung.
Haben Sie dabei Bruce Schmerzen, Lofnot?
Sie können diese Fragen stellen.
Sie fragen 3-4 Fragen.
Sie sind mit diesem Symptom interessiert.
Dann gibt es noch andere Bechwerden, die Gleisleitig-Aftretten,
zum Beispiel Bruce Schmerzen.
Sie können die Bechwerden auch noch beantworten.
Sie können sagen, sie haben Bruce Schmerzen, aber auch Bauchschmerzen.
Wenn Sie nach Bruce Schmerzen beantworten, werden die Begegnungen weniger.
Sie haben Bruce Schmerzen.
Sie haben Bruce Schmerzen, weil Sie schon mal gesagt haben, dass es Bruce Schmerzen sind.
Wie oft haben Sie Bruce Schmerzen?
Wie sieht es aus?
Sie können diese Fragen stellen.
Gibt es Probleme beim Stuhlgang?
Wie oft müssen Sie auf die Toilette gehen?
Ich würde mich gerne mit den Begegnungen beantworten.
Wie ist es, dass Sie so einen Bechwerden haben?
Dann würde ich mit den Begegnungen beantworten.
Dann fragt man, woher der Begriff kommt.
Ich habe Angst, aber ich bin etwas zu früh, aber ich habe keine Sorgen.
Heute finde ich den Bechwerden.
Bruce Schmerzen hat drei Tage lang, aber wir haben ihn seit 10 Jahren.
Das ist der Antwort.
Ich habe ihn immer so beantworten, wenn er mich fragt.
Denn er hat noch nichts gesagt.
Er hat immer noch eine Frage, wenn ich ihn ansprache.
Ich habe Angst, aber ich bin etwas zu früh, aber ich habe keine Sorgen.
Heute finde ich den Bechwerden.
Was kann es sonst sein?
Wenn Sie sich auf die Toilette bewegen,
können Sie sich die Begegnungen auf die Stresse beweisen.
Oder Sie können sich die Belastung der Physik beweisen.
Oder Sie können sich die Begegnungen auf die Stresse beweisen.
Das ist nicht unbedingt so.
Es gibt auch viele verschiedene Ursachen.
Es gibt viele verschiedene Ursachen.
Das ist nicht erblich. Das entsteht durch den Druck. Sie können einfach bequeme Schuhe vermindern.
Wie man hier die Reaktionen für die Reaktionen sagt.
Was anderes war es, Professor Çetin?
Was anderes? Wir haben Kürnaşsitöre gesagt. Schülük-Scheppich.
Ich habe es immer so gemacht. Ich habe es hier nicht gesagt.
Ich habe es bei Ekrem abgefragt.
Er fragte, ob ich so bin.
Er hat mir die Menge Alkohol gesagt.
Wie viel trinken Sie Alkohol?
Das hat er gefragt.
Als er das gesagt hat, habe ich gesagt, dass ich nicht Schülük-Scheppich bin.
Aus medizinischer Sicht ist der Tegli Alkoholkonsum zu viel.
Der Alkoholkonsum kann sehr viel sein.
Sie haben versucht, mit Alkohol aufzuhören.
Normalerweise habe ich in den mehr Alkoholmikten Reaktionen gemacht.
Weil es nicht gut ist, wenn man mit Schülük-Scheppich sagt.
Aber ich habe versucht, mit Alkoholmikten zu sprechen.
Ich habe versucht, mit Schülük-Scheppich zu sprechen.
Ich habe versucht, mit Alkoholmikten zu sprechen.
Schülük-Scheppich bedeutet natürlich, dass man mit Alkoholmikten zu viel trinkt.
Ich habe nicht die Wahl, mit Alkohol zu sprechen.
Ich habe die Frage, ob man mit Schülük-Scheppich zu viel trinkt.
Der Herr hat die Frage, ob man mit Schülük-Scheppich zu viel trinkt.
Er hat die Frage, ob man mit Schülük-Scheppich zu viel trinkt.
Ich habe die Frage, ob man mit Schülük-Scheppich zu viel trinkt.
Ich würde mal sagen...
Ich gehe zwar nicht davon aus, dass das Haus handsche removing etwas hat,
aber ich werde natürlich mit ihrem Hausarzt verbunden sein und mein
Hausarzt werden.
Und playable sein und aktuelle.
Ich glaube nicht, dass der Doktor etwas nicht sehen kann oder es nicht erledigt hat.
Aber natürlich werde ich mit dem Doktor erst einmal in Kontakt gehen, um mehr zu lernen.
Um mehr zu lernen über die Ergebnisse.
Dann werden wir uns wieder entscheiden, ob es nötig ist oder nicht.
So war es.
Die Frage, ob die Medikamente in die Pflege geändert werden,
habe ich schon in der ersten Runde.
Die Medikamente sind kein Ersatz für den Sport.
Bitte nehmen Sie keine Medikamente ohne Arztinrat ein.
Medikamente sind kein Ersatz für den Sport.
Das kann gefährlich sein, weil Medikamente für den Nebenwirkungen haben können.
Bitte nehmen Sie keine Medikamente ohne Doktor.
So war es.
So waren die Reaktionen.
Wie habe ich es vorgegeben?
Ich habe mich vorgegeben, weil ich heute Morgen aufgetretene Herzrasen und Engegefühl habe.
Laut Angaben des Patienten ist das Herzrasen plötzlich attackartig aufgetreten.
Der Attack hat ungefähr 15 Minuten gedauert.
Er berichtet, dass er seit drei Tagen bestehende Oberbauchschmerzen hat.
Nach Angaben des Patienten sind die Schmerzen nach Versier von Tofu plötzlich aufgetreten.
Er berichtet, dass die Schmerzen nicht ausstrahlen.
Die Schmerzen sind dumm, kolikartig, persistent, progredient.
Die Schmerzintensität liegt bei 3 von 10 auf der Schmerzskala.
Die Schmerzen verstärken sich bei Bewegung, während sie nach Erbrechen besser.
Darüber hinaus erwähnt er, dass er seit 10 Jahren Elchebechwerden hat.
Deswegen war er vor drei Monaten beim Hausarzt.
Damals würde bei ihm eine Ösefolgegasrodiodontoskopie durchgeführt.
Er wurde in der Differenzia Diagnose durchgeführt.
Er wurde mit Gasroentherit und Akutpankreatitis ausgeführt.
Er wurde mit Lippas und Amilas, Bestimin, als Apparativ,
als Ultraschall, als Abdomen, als Ultraschall, als Stürdiagnose bestimmen lassen.
Ich werde einen Konsül in der Abteilung für Gasroentherologie und Psychiatrie anfordern.
Sollte sich meine Verdacht Diagnose bestätigen, werde ich die Patienten ambulant behandeln.
Die Patienten sollte als symptomatische Behandlung wie Analgetik, Spasmodik, Antiemetik,
gegebenenfalls Protonpomphema, erhalten.
Lebensstilveränderung spielt hier eine große Rolle.
Zum Beispiel, ich kann nicht erinnern, ob ich jetzt über Gewicht mitgebracht habe,
oder ob ich jetzt über Gewicht mitgebracht habe.
Ich würde das so sagen.
Normalerweise ist die Reisdarm-Syndrom eine Abwechslung.
Man kann alles nach dem Ausdruck ausbreiten.
Deswegen ist es mir sehr schrecklich, eine Reisdarm-Syndrom-Aufnahme zu machen.
Aber leider gibt es solche Fakten fast überall.
Es gibt solche Fakten, die die Menschen oft in der Hand haben,
weil sie sehr oft in der Hand sind.
Was ist der grundlegende Faktor, den Reisdarm-Syndrom uns anzusehen?
Daher kann man die Reisdarm-Syndrom-Aufnahme nicht verarbeiten.
Es gibt keine Patologik, das ist auch nicht so.
Wenn man von der Reisdarm-Syndrom-Aufnahme stammt,
und man nicht in einer Tätigkeit denkt,
wie ein Reisdarm-Syndrom ist,
dann kann man sich die Reisdarm-Syndrom-Aufnahme nicht anregen.
Wenn man von der Reisdarm-Syndrom-Aufnahme sagt,
das ist eine Patologik und es ist nicht so,
dass man sich nicht um die Reisdarm-Syndrom-Aufnahme bewegen kann,
Seht nur zwei und konzentriere dich auf sie.
Ich habe gesagt, dass ich Acute Pancreatitis und Gastroenteritis wähle.
Warum Acute Pancreatitis?
Weil es mit Obaba-Akshimersin gibt.
Deswegen nenne ich Acute Pancreatitis.
Und ich dachte, dass ich Acute Pancreatitis, wenn eine Frage kommt,
dann kann ich das besser beantworten.
Ich habe eine Kurs von ihm gemacht.
Deswegen kann ich seine Fragen besser beantworten.
Warum Acute Pancreatitis?
Ich habe nach dem Essen eine Anzeige,
es gibt Durkfalli, Erbrahana, 3 Tage.
Deswegen wähle ich Acute Pancreatitis.
Aber man kann das auch mit Ulcosventrikul,
Acute Pancreatitis, Acute Coronary Syndrome,
das kann man auch mit Lukrankite nennen.
Es gibt also etwas, was man mit jedem sagen kann.
Was wichtig ist, wie du das beantworten kannst.
Warum hast du das gedacht?
Wähle etwas.
Wenn du das fragen willst, sage ich das hier.
Ich mache das hier.
Das wichtigste ist, das zu beantworten.
Ich habe eine Kurs von Acute Pancreatitis.
Sind es andere Fragen oder Anwendungen?
Nein.